hello i'm marie biggs welcoming you to
act as at work what you're about to
watch is a public rehearsal of a short
scene from a play shakespeare's the
comedy of errors my two actors are
currently in the third and final year of
the acting track of the Yale School of
Drama our professional theatre training
program they'll begin by giving you a
short context for the scene before
running it through once script in add
I'll then comment on what we've seen
from the back of the room maybe there
will be some three-way exchange then
they'll do it again or bits of it again
in light of my remarks before we take a
break for questions or observations from
any of you finally we'll wrap up the
hour with the whole scene again that's
best as our actors can manage it in this
way we hope you'll get an idea in
miniature of what happens between actors
and a director in bringing any play from
the page to a public performance let's
get started hello howdy um so I guess
we're supposed to give you some context
yeah um yeah um so I will playing a
booty onna
and luciana sister Adriana will be
behind that door imaginatively uh we are
coming in from the house where this
taken Lee we think that this is her
husband now the reason that we think
that this is her husband is because he
is her husband's twin when separated at
birth this is from a play comedy of
errors me and my brother separated at
birth I happen to travel to the land
where he has set up shop and I've been
mistaken by the town and most recently
by his wife to be him Antipolis of
ephesus so she's taken me into the house
and convinced me that um I am her
husband and in the meantime I've I've
got eyes for another woman in the house
and we're going to see what happens
we can just add the most remarkable
coincidence of all is that you have a
first name
yes brother so when you are cool
shyffilis
it's no surprise right my name yeah we
should add that you're you're supposed
wife and Rihanna has been giving you a
very hard time for being gone from the
house rather more than she likes it's
true right Marie I can't ignore yeah
okay ah okay great never mind the voice
for fear the darkness all right it's
over to you let's have a first man at
the scene
thank you shall Antipolis even in the
spring of love bad luck Springs right
shall no any building were so ruinous if
you did Wed my sister for her wealth
then for her wealthy use her with more
kindness or if you like another do it
myself
muffle your false love is what some show
blindness let all my sister read it in
your eye like my tongue my own chains
order look sweet be fair uh um
disloyalty apparel vice like virtues
Harbinger teach tune the carriage of a
Holy Saint ah ah secret both what needs
to be painted last poor women make us
but believe being compact of credit that
you
love us though the arm though others
have the arm show us the sleeve we in
your motion turn and you may move us
therefore good brother ah hit you in
again comfort my sister cheer her call
her wife
tis holy sport to be a little vain when
the sweet breath of flattery conquers
strife sweet mistress what my name is
else I know not know by what wonder you
do a hit of mine less in your knowledge
and your grace you showed not then RS
wonder more than earth divine teach me
dear creature how to think and speak lay
open to my lastly gross conceit
smothered in errors spiegel shallow weak
the folded meaning in thy words deceit
against my soul's pure truth while labor
you to make it wonder in an unknown
field are you a god would you create me
new transform me then and to your power
I will yield but if that I am I then
well I know your weeping sister is no
wife of mine nor to her bed
no homage do I owe far more far more to
you do I decline Oh train me not sweet
mermaid with I note to drown me in my
sister's flood of Tears sing siren for
thyself and I will don't spread or the
silver waves thy golden hair
and as a bet I'll take them there and
lie and in that glorious supposition
think he gains by death that hath such
means to die what are you mad that you
do reason thus not mad but but made it
how I do not guess it is a fault that
that spring it from your eye gazing on
your beams fair Sun being by mmm gaze
where you should and this will clear
your sight as good to wink sweet love as
look on night oh do me love call my
sister so thy sisters sister my sister
no it is myself mine own selves better
part mine eyes clear I my dear hearts
dearer heart my food my fortune and my
sweet hopes aim my soul Earth's heaven
and My heavens claim all this is my
sister or else should be called myself
sister sweet
for I am the V will I love and with me
lead my life thou hast no husband yet
nor I no wife give me the hand Oh sir
soft hold yourself uh I'll fetch my
sister and I'll get her good will
all right thank you you showed us how
you were feeling your way into and
through the scene when we do it again
and you'll probably want to pick up the
pace a little bit yeah that lowest line
and off of loose edges yes Express is
one of the most remarkable changes
bribed or art removed in all of
traumatic literature right because she's
been saying no no no never know
throughout and then suddenly she says
well I see what my sister thinks about
in Greece we'll go off to the Bahamas
together all right so how do you explain
and what you're thinking about that
let's acknowledge that this play is not
meant to be entirely realistic right
Shakespeare's comedies generally on
certainly the early ones and this makes
a good place for being the earliest
player that Shakespeare wrote we don't
know exactly but you know 15 1991 so the
beginning of its career it's also
distinguished by the fact that there's
an unusual amount of rhyme in it now we
know that Shakespeare wrote mostly in
first 70% of the whole corpus is in
verse and most of that versus black
clerks right unrhymed iambic pentameter
but this has an unusually high count
about a quarter of the verse in this
play is in rhymed verse okay not a
rhyming couplets as in the scene for
example but nevertheless right so that's
a pointer towards the artifice of the
situation comedy expects a certain
amount or allows for a certain amount of
convention yeah but I'm not myself
convinced that that is really good
enough to explain what appears to be a
total character switch on behalf of on
the part of Luciano
so how do you feel as playing this three
diamond
character and deal with it um I I think
that Luciana is um well on her way to
being a spinster um and so it's very
possible that the in one interpretation
you know she'll take what she can get um
I am a romantic and so I like to think
that it's kind of like that that there
was a ping the first time that we saw
each other but that it is it it's
absolutely horrible we should never this
is a bad idea and so I think that um he
wins her over with his earnest love so
if you're on the way to being the maid
nagy this you might see as you're well
another opportunity - yes but of course
you are speaking the language of
propriety by want propriety almost all
the way through the speech and then you
flap all those conventions right you
know the horse wasn't exactly easy in
1591 so how you actually planned this to
work out us is not so easy all right
you gave a couple of hints physical and
vocal hints before you go up to the line
which I thought was very helpful
you didn't just hit it out of the blue I
have a couple of questions about the
meaning that actually both for you and
tifos you describe yourself as not mad
but mated how I do not know what does
mated mean there I mean I took it as in
love not not not mad out of my senses
but madly in in love uh fine yes it
probably actually carries the
Elizabethan meaning of being overcome by
something presumably there's also a pun
on making in the world made sense yeah
the early Shakespeare particularly is
full of puns and this is probably one
example a couple of lines later you say
she says gaze where you should and if I
could read this myself and that
your site which you respond as good to
wink
sweet love as look all night
what does wink mean well for me for me
it's just nothing I mean I mean if she's
the Sun and Adriana is the night I'd
rather I'd rather look at nothing than
have to look at her sister right
but wink and Elizabethan English always
means to shut one's eyes right not right
bling right so basically you're saying I
might as well have my eyes closed for
all the beauty I can see in her she's
the kind of the magic creature all right
I think I was the meaning is clear yeah
no I would say the main acting problem
in this scene is what the non speaker is
doing even to these two massive
monologues yeah really
each it's neither is a soliloquy each is
addressed to the other and it's quite a
problem in a way for the other to figure
out why he or she doesn't interrupt do
you have any simple answer to that why
sheet it doesn't allow for example
antipolis to break into this tirade of
abuse and vice versa why doesn't she say
to him look enough I'm going inside or
get you inside oh I mean I I would say
that I want to hear her one I want to
hear her speak but two I want to hear
her whole argument so that I can negate
I can clear all worries that she has
like tell me everything you don't think
is going to be fine and we're gonna make
it okay could be could be you know like
is you know Shakespeare is so much about
argument and I want to hear her argument
so that I can then take it off um could
just be the sound of her voice that
sounds to me you're fairly good reason
oh yeah yeah also raff along right keep
going what about you Luciana um I I
think that I'll hear him because what
he's saying is so lovely I mean I stop I
think um but there is a time and a place
and we need to cut it off at a certain
moment I
so think that in maybe a longer
rehearsal period um I would love to have
worked with being able to like actually
find the impulses for each line off of
whatever it is that he's doing yeah yeah
there's something in that of like oh
this is working I'm going to keep going
and so until it's not going to work and
then I'm going to have to okay we can
see a little bit more of both of those
when I do it again but I like your idea
Luciana that you don't mind the sound of
his voice even if what he's actually
saying it is based on principle repulsor
- you know let's do a little exercise
could you bring one of those chairs to
center stage all right now I brought
along a couple of props thinking we
might find them useful and I want to try
them so Luciana look you go to the
podium upstage set where you will find a
book if it's still there and a shawl all
right now could you get out of the way
please and her tavella's all right now
let's put the shawl over your head for
maiden modesty and let's go with this
notion that she is a very modest
creature in fact let's get extreme'
about this sure she's thinking of
entering a convent I just think of her
as a printer though I brought the
largest Bible I could um it's the
Catholic bottle of judgment anyway think
of yourself as the prototypical Isabella
in measure for measure right so you are
reading a Holy Scripture great and
you're reading it to yourself I don't
want any of the text for a minute right
but you're thoroughly absorbed in it and
let's assume that Antipolis approaches
from the aisle over there
yes and he sees his prize as it were and
let's assume that you do not notice him
for the longest possible time or if you
pretend not to notice him until he
somehow other forces himself on your
attention okay but you're a very serious
reader and I think there's a bookmark in
there isn't that and we're just I mean
that's a convenient place and not that
you can't read anything out loud for the
moment right but they get serious about
the opening chapter of Matthew's Gospel
right all right any time please
Antipolis
all right so now let's spin a variant on
that let's improvise some dialog we
don't want the Shakespeare just you know
whatever comes into your head both of
you to get some kind of dialogue going
it should be in the spirit of the scene
obviously so why don't you try another
angle Chris come up it down this aisle
maybe you should look yes maybe you
should look at it from this side
oh and think about you know going around
behind her trying to catch your
attention from all sides great and you
can take time to get into any speech
alright once again
oh sorry I didn't mean to bother you
just walking through are you looking for
my sister
no what's it what's that you're you're
reading a Bible fine book have you
gotten to the part yet uh I won't give
it away hey oh sorry let me just have
you quite forgot a husband's our faces
well yeah all right now um one more time
at this time use the words of the
opening chapter of Matthew to keep him
at a distance in fact let's assume that
you're mumbling them to yourself
barely audibly when you first sense him
and then you can build the volume to
drown out his real speech from
Shakespeare right great so it comes from
an I'll again for is Chris and it's our
so we're starting with my texture
coastal state we're now starting with
your tax rate and we'll have this
simultaneous right right each of you try
to ride over the other
Salman Salman was the father of boa
rehab being his mother philosopher what
your name is else I know I know by what
wonder you do hit of mine David was the
father of Solomon last when you're
wondering you brief you show not in our
Father
Alondra am you more than Earth divided
chief of me my dear
Krieger our end fathers
one of the little eyes there I'm glad
you brought that secondary because I'd
like to try a completely different
approach to see the exact opposite from
the way you played it first time around
and whether or not we would go with this
or perhaps more likely absorb some of it
into a final version let's try it now
this time stay with the Bible and you're
reading and he sits rather modestly down
next to you and this becomes a really
private conversation in which you're
using the Bible the text of the Bible to
instill in him the proper memory of
faithful behavior to his wife right okay
and then let's suppose that when you
come back at her you've already
despaired of achieving anything right
and uh hoping against hope that she will
give you what you asked for
okay um I think we'll begin it from the
beginning of the scene that we won't
finish the scene all right so let's take
it from there
let's have you coming in in some kind of
depression because you've given up hope
but there she is you'll give it a shot
and you you would like the text that I
am yeah you know the real check shows
this dead weight so you are rebuking him
but rather nicely yeah and in fact since
the pretty much the last time we saw you
and your sister she told you to mind
your own business you know anything
about marriage you're a single woman can
keep out of it so maybe you're feeling a
little uncomfortable about actually
interfering in the marriage though with
him rather than with your sister this
time right right there's a kind of
awkwardness from your side of things and
on a different kind of awkwardness from
his right yeah let's try it from the top
you
and maybe that you have quite forgot a
husband's office shall antipholus being
in the spring of love iane in the spring
of love thy love Springs Rob shall love
in building grow so ruinous if you did
Wed my sister for her wealth then for
her wealth use her with more kindness or
if you like elsewhere
do it myself muffle your false love with
some show of blindness let not my sister
read it in your eye be thy tongue be not
by tongue thy own shames orator look
sweet be fair become disloyalty apparel
vice like virtues Harbinger bear a fair
presence though your heart be tainted
teach them the carriage of the Holy
Saint people's true it would be secret
false what need she be acquainted house
for women make us but believe being
compact if credited you love us others
have the arms show us the sleeve we in
your motion turn and you may move us
then gentle brother gets you too might
get you to your then gentle brother get
you in again comfort my sister cheer her
call her wife just holy sport to be a
little vain my sweet breath of
flattering comfort
strife sweet mistress well your name is
else I know not nor by what wonder you
do hit of mine less in your wonder and
your grace you show not than our Earth's
wonder more than earth divine teach me
dear creature how to think and speak lay
open to my earthly gross conceit
smothered in errors feeble shallow weak
the folded meaning in your words deceit
all right I think we can stop this so
it's becoming the tragedy of errors now
isn't it right but of course if you
start to think about this in realistic
terms it's a pretty bad situation right
right and so they're both of them
playing with fire one point or another
in the scene but you can see I think
from what they did then the
possibilities underlying the same text
and what can be done with them in a full
performance could we have the house
lights back on and we'll take a little
time now to answer any questions you may
have or listen to your comments on the
scene and then the actress will do the
whole thing again perfectly perfectly
there is a traveling mic we can't really
see hands but if you would like to ask a
question put your hand up and somebody
will come to you we have a hand here who
are you I think it's for the recording
actually when it give it yes well
actually why don't you start because we
can always repeat the question if it's
not here
so quick have you worked and other
things together a lot have you done
scenes together have you done scenes
together that would promote this kind of
thing um so we've been in school
together now for about two years
we're starting our third year two years
in some change yeah yeah and actually we
were we auditioned on the same day -
yeah like our Saturday like you know
each day there's 100 people and by the
end of the day there was like five and
we were we were in the same group there
so um yeah yeah we've I mean
we've watched each other do just about
anything you want to see and then a lot
of stuff you don't want to see well
shows I think in this because I mean
just per the professor's instructions
you were just so easily able to know
what to do so I thought there's only 16
members it's 16 in your year is nothing
17 so you know three years together they
know probably more about one another
than they ever wanted out but they
certainly have to you know muscle in
together and make the best of it yeah
you did somebody else put your hand up
and they mic will come your way
hello question to Professor bigs are
have you worked with this scene uh with
the actors before in preparation for
this class was it the first run-through
yes yeah thanks for asking that we met
two nights ago and read through the
scene basically to make sure of it you
know that we've taken care of any
textual problems because we didn't want
to spend a lot of time here dealing with
meaning I know I asked two questions
about meeting which I should have asked
two nights ago and didn't we spent about
half an hour doing that now for all I
know the two actors may have spent some
time with each other but the idea is to
come at this early on imagining this is
a microscope of the whole process of
bringing a play not just a scene from
the page to a you know public
presentation and by the end of this hour
which is fast approaching
we hope you know we you will see what
can be done within an hour as a sample
of what can be done over a period of
four or five weeks you also direct as
part of your teaching at the Yale School
of Drama you directly sit this is the
only program I do with drama school
students I do direct I teach acting in
your college especially Shakespeare
acting but and I direct undergraduate
productions typically every other year
and with an emphasis on Shakespeare
historically I've directed I think 14
Shakespeare production not all here
admittedly but mostly with
undergraduates but this is not about
directing a full production in a way
that's nice because it focuses entirely
on what the actors are doing you don't
have to think about you know the so
called production values which can get
in the way and they're simply not
available here to the to the actors
I ask them to bring it you know to wear
clothes modern clothes that would be
roughly suitable for the situation but
that really is the only thing that goes
even an inch or two beyond their acting
so if you were to imagine this was going
to be your production or comedy of
errors how much time do the students
have to actually read the play before
you start blocking it if you're asking
me as a director yes
now that's bound to vary according to
the time available for the whole thing
now in recent years the undergraduate
productions that I have directed have
had the luxury of a whole semester it's
built into the curriculum and so we
spend in a lot of time reading moving it
around but not setting setting the
blocking that's a bit of a luxury and it
depends on the site well not so much the
size of the cast but on the number of
people on stage at any one time as
anybody who's in the theater will
immediately
they recognize any two-person scene can
sometimes be left to the actors to block
differently every time within certain
limits you pretty much got to define
entrances and exits but the more people
you have on stage and the smaller the
stage the more the director has to be on
the ball about getting the traffic
moving earlier than perhaps otherwise is
to serve you can't leave everything to
chance I don't know how that squares
with your experience I mean you were
both in the as you like it and you've
done other full productions how long did
you have for those productions and
what's the process similar to what I've
described or not um in school in a
varies on the project um I know that
thesis shows have a lot longer is that
right these are shows have have longer
to rehearse what is the thesis show
thesis show is when a director there are
three directors every year for three
years and those three directors in their
final year are given the opportunity to
and the money time to put on a really
spectacular show something that they
have created of their choosing and with
a thesis show I think that you get about
a month and like and in a crazy way ten
days for tech which is that the
technical part of the rehearsal and
that's kind of unheard of in in the
Shakespeare that we did here uh two
gents I think that we probably had in
rehearsal in the room I think we had
about three and a half weeks and that
and in terms of like how long do you
have before like your question was how
long do you read yeah like how long do
you spend I'm absorbing the absorbing
the text as much as you can
yes I mean if you get it a week before
you spend every second if you get it a
month before hopefully you still spend
every second just because so much of our
job relies on relies on us being able to
show up to a room and be able to play um
like a the summer we were both in a
Yale summer cabaret and we had 12 day
rehearsal processes which are incredibly
incredibly short and I remember someone
said in tech including tech only 12 days
to do a show and you know it's really
when it's that tight it really boils
down to like my job is to know my lines
and like the thing is once I show up to
rehearsal and I know my lines my my work
is done and I can begin to play yeah
so I want to show up with as much of the
work out of the way so I can just I can
just watch her foot and try and touch it
or I can watch your foot priming for the
page you know because if you're in your
book you're not going to notice what's
actually happening in front of you and
our job is to react and respond to
what's actually happening in the room at
that moment on that night at that hour
at that minute yeah thank you you have a
hand here I think well the mic is
reaching this doesn't have you
understudied says he at the rep I know
that Chris has what did you understood
II um I got to understudy the realistic
Jones's which is a will you know play I
got to understand Johanna days character
uh-huh did you go on and did not the rep
season really doesn't give more than
about four weeks to actual performances
there yeah but Chris you understudied uh
yeah
did you go on or not I did not go on but
I knew the entire script so there you go
I learned the entire role and we have
understudy rehearsals where we all the
understudies go on and basically go
through the play together
oh I got I got to play Hamlet over five
days without an audience but you know
I'll do it I'll do it again you learned
all 1400 lines given two handed you know
there's only 350 lines short of the
whole of the comedy of errors the whole
play itself actually is Shakespeare
shortest play yeah yes I'm not a theater
person but when I see a master class I'm
always shocked how within different that
you can how different it can be and how
little it's in is in the words you know
or how much Brera there is in the non
word
art and does that feel that to you when
you like when you do the two or three
things here does each one feel really
quite different to you um I think so I
think that the thing that for the the
words are incredibly important and I
think it's actually the argument that's
incredibly important and the argument
will never change regardless of how it
is that I choose to attack that argument
attack is kind of a violent word I don't
like it but but how I choose to use it
to my advantage um and so you know if if
he had a suspended on something and we
had to swing to each other you know I
don't know another version um that would
change the way that I used my argument
with the argument itself never changes
that make sense that kind of weird okay
yeah there's something in like you know
these words were written hundreds of
years ago and why are we still doing
them because in this moment with these
people it's new it's different and so
this was kind of a little microcosm of
every time someone else approaches this
scene it will never be the same and and
it's N and what will end the miracle is
that you don't have to try to make it
different each new I mean he gave us new
given circumstances or new physical
actions and simply by doing that I
didn't have to show you a really
different take on the scene I just had
to pursue the scene with whatever was
given and it all of a sudden informed
there's a whole there's a whole lot of
freedom in uh in specificity yeah and
and I'm really narrowing down okay this
time you're looking at her left ear and
this time you're you you want to paint
her with you know like this little silly
images or phrases can really um
transform what we're doing thank you I
have a question for you that did you
feel that any of the exercises were
untrue to the script or expressions
legitimate expressions possible
expressions of the script they were
untrue which is even more shocking time
it given the constancy of the word
the different approaches and I think
this sort of similarity of feeling but
also the difference at the same time I
mean they're both seem to be both there
Chris used a technical phrase given
circumstances which comes out of acting
theory and it can mean several things it
the given circumstances include the
physical bodies and voices of the actors
they include a given script which the
assumption is you're not going to change
but then as he was getting at they also
include suggestions from a director who
can replace either the physical action
of the scene or let's say that in order
to steer the actors in a slightly
different direction that's the most
common use I think of the phrase given
circumstances and it's critical to what
any actor does yeah yeah without giving
circumstances you have no idea where you
are or what you're supposed to be doing
we have a hand up front here so I had a
question about the program and not about
today's lecture for you guys so um the
Yale Drama School is really famous I'm
curious how you found it to be different
than what you expected ha totally yeah
question um-hmm how did I it it was a
yeah it's a lot harder than I thought it
was gonna be um I didn't they were like
it's really hard you're not gonna sleep
a lot and I'm like yeah oh they did were
not kidding
they weren't joking um I'm sick right
now
actually I tried to stay up last night
learning lines and also doing the rest
of my homework and it was I think I
might have gone to sleep before that I
mean and that's silly like that whatever
who cares go to like it's sleep but I
think that the other thing that I wasn't
expecting was how incredibly talented
the people that I work with are how in
love with their jobs our
t is they are like they are so
passionate and they're so amazing and
it's such a great thing to learn from
because you know I kind of came from a
small community of theatres and everyone
there was pretty jaded and these people
were so alive with it and it it changes
everything when you love your job but
changes everything and also I think that
the other things that that I thought you
know I thought that I was going to leave
here and like I was going to get the
acting secret like they were gonna teach
me the secret there's no secret and I
was so disappointing it's just working
you just work and keep working and
working yeah it reminds me a little bit
of starts play no exit try to get drama
school people to do anything outside
their curriculum is not easy so I'm
particularly grateful to these two and I
had no idea I had no idea that you
weren't feeling well it didn't show
Chris how would you respond each of you
of course spent time out before coming
here it's unusual not a unique but
unusual for somebody to be accepted in
the drama school is the acting program
straight out of college and you I would
think are probably closer to the average
you did five years and you do two years
I think yeah so that's really a second
question why after this experience in
the real professional world did you want
to go back to school wasn't that a
regression well so so I'll answer that
question person to be Thai in this list
the thing so I was in New York and I was
seeing these great actors work and I
noticed that they had gone to graduate
school and I I auditioned without
knowing that I wanted to come I just
auditioned to see what the opportunity
would present and when I got in I
realized that it was I realized that
putting my ego aside I just I want to
work and it's three years of work you
know for me it's not a regression for me
it's three years of working with the
best people that I've ever met
on amazing plays with with professors
who care
and are able to push me further than I
can push myself sometimes so in that
respect I think I kind of won you know I
mean I mean this doesn't exist and I
know and this isn't the real world this
is a really great petri dish that kind
of gets to jumpstart a lot of things in
which I'll hopefully work on for the
rest of my life when I when I have a
life and I think what's been so
surprising about this this program is
how is how personal it feels I don't
feel like I'm going to the Yale School
of Drama yeah I feel like I'm feel like
feel like I feel like I don't feel like
I'm going to therapy but I but but but
but I do feel I do feel personal
relationships to the lessons that we're
learning the people who are here and to
the institution it's it's it's no longer
an institution to me and that was really
surprising that it wasn't a place I was
going to go to and you know and get beat
up by and come out looking like looking
castable this is a place that has really
I think I think this place changes
depending on who's here I think the
school actually changes itself to
accommodate the students and the faculty
that are here and that's been awesome to
be a part of to be a part of making this
place what it is and I hope you agree
that a lot of the credit for what you
have enjoyed is due to the Dean of the
school and artistic director of the Yale
rep James Bundy time for maybe one more
question I think you have a hand there
oh you have a hand back there and then
maybe we can go across the room and
finish with that that person is perfect
this is probably a little out in left
field but I'm just curious about um
particularly worried Briggs what your
take is on the Josh Whedon much ado
about nothing which is I think shot
under in you know in a very short period
of time and yet is very accessible
Shakespeare and stars an XEL student I
mean one of the rules well um the actor
playing Claudio Fran Kranz yeah was in
my acting class when he was here and we
stayed in touch and we become friends
he was barricading me with emails during
the late summer what do you think of
much ado about nothing I'm dying for an
opinion
well it didn't show publicly in New
Haven and the DVD came out three days
ago right so I have an excuse for not
having seen it yet but as soon as it
gets into the film Study Center I have a
special order for it I will see it and I
will report at least to one of the
actors on it but the word about it not
very good and in a friend has a history
with Joss Whedon he was in the dollhouse
TV series together and was last seen of
course on Broadway in the Philip Seymour
Hoffman death for salesmen so and he was
very happy with the experience so maybe
we should move to another question and
this will be rich and then we'll run the
scene again while you still here um I
again just like to get back to to the
play um
what's not delineated um in this in the
way you perform if obvious reasons is
the location where is this encounter
taking place it could have actually been
in a chapel in which case um you know he
comes upon her in a chapel because he's
so
pressed or out in a garden or in one of
the rooms um and how would the location
impact on the kind of encounter that
takes place between them um I
the the location is enormous and I think
that the the difference between a garden
and a room I mean the moment that Chris
shut the door it changed the space you
know it suddenly becomes a lot more
dangerous um it so Shakespeare doesn't
really tell us other than in the text
he doesn't have stage directions that
like actually isn't true those were
written in by editors so you kind of
have to make it up I think that the
obvious thought is yeah the it's
definitely at our house because we've
had we've been having dinner um but
we're away from Adriana so I don't know
like in another room problem and then we
would like make it more specific um like
maybe the garden would be lovely
very romantic there's like a garden in
the back of the house yeah the scene
before this takes place outside of this
house or outside of Adriana's house with
my twin banging and saying let me in and
I'm saying you're crazy you're already
here what's wrong with you so so I mean
yeah in the text it doesn't say clearly
but I would assume this is in Adriana
Adriana's house where Luciana also lives
and now my house oh yeah yeah set design
is is a whole other element that informs
so much and that the director really
gets to choose how much they wanted to
be a part of it how you know a lot of
Shakespeare's Emily just empties empty
spaces we just saw production of McBee
Scottish play Etta isn't really a
theatre Macbeth at the at Hartford stage
sorry and and and it was completely
blank it's just a thrust without any set
and they did the whole play it was
beautiful so it's possible to go to
nothing and it's possible to have levers
and drawers and setting a table and
throwing plates on the ground and you
know that's fun too
yeah good well thank you I think we have
time to see the whole scene once again
you have a choice with
to use furniture or not but you're not
to use scripts this time throw them to
the wind that's my choice
we'll be a whole in just in case I think
I need to hold my just in case we're
just gonna we're gonna hold them but
we're not gonna use them and may it be
that you have quite forgot a husband's
office shall antipholus in in the spring
of love thy love Springs rot can love in
building grow so ruinous if you did Wed
my sister for her wealth then for her
wealth sake use her with more kindness
or if you like elsewhere do it by
stealth muffle muffle your false love
with some show of blindness uh-uh not my
sister read it in your eye let not my
tongue be thy own shames orator look
sweet be fair become disloyalty apparel
vice like virtues Harbinger bear fair
presents though your heart is tainted
teach then the carriage of a Holy Saint
be secret false what what need she be
acquainted Oh last poor women huh make
us but believe being compact of credit
that you you love us hmm though others
have the arm you show us the sleeve we
in your motion turn and you may move us
then gentle brother gets you in again
comfort my sister cheer her call her
white
tis holy sport to be a little vain one
sweet breath of flattery comfort strife
sweet mistress Oh your name is else I
know not nor by what wonder you do hit
of mine less in your wonder and your
grace you show not then our Earth's
wonder more than Earth divine teach me
dear creature how to think and speak now
open to my earthy gross conceit ah
smother than errors spiegel shallow weak
the hidden meaning of your words deceit
against my soul's pure truth why labor
you to make it wander in an unknown
field are you a God would you create me
new
transform me then until your power yield
but if that I am I and well I know your
weeping sister is no wife of mine nor to
her bed
no homage do I owe far more far more to
you do I decline Oh train me not sweet
mermaid if I note to drown me and my
sister's flood of Tears sing
siren for thyself and I will don't
spread or the silver waves thy golden
hairs and as a bet I'll take them there
and lie and in that glorious supposition
pinky gains by death that hath such
means to die let love being light be
drowned if she sink are you mad that you
do reason us not mad but mated how I do
not guess ah ah oh it is a fault that
spring youth from your eye for gazing on
your beams fair Sun being by gaze upon
my sister gaze where you should and that
will clear your sight it's good to wait
sweet love is look on night why call you
me love call my sister so my sister
sister that's my sister no no no no what
is myself my own selfs better part mine
eyes clear I my dear hearts dearer heart
my food my fortune my sweet hopes aim my
soul Earth's heaven and My heavens claim
office
my sister is or else should be myself
sister sweet
for I am V V will I love and with the
lead my life
thou hast no husband yet nor I no wife
give me your hand
Oh soft sir I'll go to my sister and get
her good will
you